the gyro can experience speaking of
which is Rachel ostrich gonna fight
Paige Vanzant how many people gonna be
watching that fight we're backing off
this guy watched fight ever yeah and
they're talking about it too like Paige
had it on her that it's gonna be the
hottest fight ever ever yeah Rachel
Austen [ __ ] is wearing [ __ ] fur coat
within the staredown just to deny me
make that a pay-per-view main of I don't
want Paige to lose any weight though
when she's all thick like that so Center
good so so much healthier did you see
her husband
dude he tapped out boogie man I was
super impressed I said monster I sent
him a message on Instagram good dude
not only that his [ __ ] explosive
takedown defense or as a if submission
defense was insane insane the way he
exploded out of things I was very
impressed that's jail Simmons thing
right yes yeah very impressed with his
submission though the fact that he
caught look boogeyman is a real tippet
10th planet jiu-jitsu blackbelt
international competitor it's all he
does tapped out Sakuraba yeah that's all
he does yeah that's his profession he's
amazing Austin man afford to MMA fighter
former wrestler he's buddies and
pictures naked with his girl I was like
alright let me go roll this dude up what
a stud he's really strong the nicest guy
in the world
I bet he is the way he tapped him with
that head and arm choke - he was in half
guard he could tap quick - it must been
a lot of pressure nobody messing an
attack [ __ ] he's he's a gorilla man
he's so strong
the way he threw him around - I was like
I was so impressed at how he got out of
that arm bar the way explodes out of
stuff like really explosive just dud
really strong guy stuff but the clamp
down on that head and arm choke and
apparently according to jail Charles was
doing the commentary in the pay-per-view
he said that's
Austin's favorite city to go to is this
submission higher ground
yeah the [ __ ] was super underground
super it was happening with no idea yeah
seven people watched
did you see Vinny Magalhaes refusing the
tap though and Craig Jones snapped his
arm it's snapped his a Oh No Danny broke
his tibia she's
till you're his fibula one of his name
one of his shin Bob's his [ __ ] broke
this now yeah too much pride but you
could see the angle it's got him in the
heel hook and you can see the angle that
is his leg is in where all the pressures
on it and then you see it go kind of
sideways and you're like that can't be
good and apparently they were talking
well they weren't talking I watched the
match and chills like what are they
saying to each other but Vinny was
saying he broke my leg while they're
still going holy [ __ ] yeah yeah we got
it more - what a grab stud you grab that
same leg more than once so he's grinding
on it with he's got this broken shin
bone and he's digging on it with another
heel hook I wonder how many people watch
that for drugs three degenerates I mean
it's on UFC fight pass there it is like
so he gets it and Craig Jones by the way
one of the very best grapplers on the
planet Earth yes so look and Vinny was
like I don't tap to heal hooks
I don't tap to heals me said I don't tap
to leg locks so right there yeah he got
up weird - like his left leg is shot
right there
watch again on Instagram so he snapped
that [ __ ] so he's got it it's a terrible
angle - look right there [ __ ] so it's
broken so he broke the bottom of his
shin and that's really dangerous -
because when you get a break like that
you get infections it's true he'd lose
the leg it's really bad such a stud oh
he's an animal didn't he's an animal I
mean he's basically all weight on his
right leg but how much that dude's grown
since the Ultimate Fighter a lot he got
to the finals of that pfl million dollar
thing
[Applause]